he's my wonderful donkey there so hello
he want to come out and she tells me of
course am i stupid freedom she said oh
it's about time you got here yeah here
we are a donkey that's weird
it was quite magical talking to animals
because they're sharing their
experiences with you they're giving you
a perspective into their world and we go
and see the others yeah okay
I do converse of my pets on a day-to-day
basis and we chat about the most unusual
things I've heard the lectures on
American politics come closer what you
just yum-yum there's also in short
behave now he talks about crime shows of
all things we have the TV on should be
outside the door watching it this is
from her position it's like I've
actually got a really good storyline but
they've got to have strong characters to
it she'd bring it together probably the
thing that I learned as a child is that
you do get one bad or a lot of
information from the animals it just
comes in all the time you go outside the
birds are talking to you you sit on the
grass the worms are talking to you I'm
getting a little bit close to you
because I didn't realise I did she taken
some spider webs down
I know think he's lost phase just on the
house he's going to have a Skype session
with my client and America because she's
got a new kitten but the cousins gone
missing hi tell me where you've locked I
will just keep talking to her and see if
we can get him to come out and show
himself well he can't have been um d
will he hear us right now
No
to communicate with any animal they
don't have to be present with me so what
I'm trying to do is just get your fun to
share better today this is just random
impressions that have come through it
was my game I will be found
when your child the power of imagination
is so powerful I mean what is reality
and what's not reality I remember a few
childhood experiences where the animals
would be telling me things and I would
tell my mum and she would say animals
don't talk it's curtains hello gorgeous
he's actually just so relieved he's
enjoyed all the information exciting for
him you're wonderful with what you do I
feel more connected with the animals it
brings joy and also brings a little
sorrow and a little pain but I don't
know what I would do if I didn't have
you